avec vous Antoine Mariotti bonjour
Antoine bonjour la centrale nucléaire de
zapporijab a bien le rappeler à
l'instant c'est l'une des plus
importantes c'est la plus importante
d'Europe elle est contrôlée par les
russes depuis les premières semaines de
la guerre et se trouve sur cette ligne
de front est-ce qu'on sait ce qui s'est
passé ce weekend alors en effet les
contrôlés par les Russes qui sont
accusés de mettre des troupes à
l'intérieur et d'avoir des missiles
aussi à l'intérieur mais il y a aussi
des techniciens Ukrainiens qui qui sont
toujours dans cette centrale on sait
qu'il y a entre 12 et 20 missiles
environ qui ont été lancés directement
sur la centrale entre samedi soir et
dimanche matin il y a deux inspecteurs
de la i.a qui sont en permanence sur
cette centrale et qui ce matin sont en
train de sortir pour inspecter les
dégâts et voir concrètement TOUT ce qui
a été précisément touché ou pas
commençons par les aspirations peut-être
déjà il n'y a pas eu d'impact direct sur
les systèmes clés de sûreté ou de
sécurité nucléaire ça veut dire qu'aucun
des six réacteurs nucléaires de la
centrale de zapporica n'a été touché les
niveaux de radiation sont donc sur le
site sont restés normaux ce qui est
quand même la priorité et il n'y a pas
eu de victimes non plus et
l'alimentation électrique externe de la
centrale qui a été interrompu à
plusieurs reprises depuis le début du
conflit en mars dernier n'a pas non plus
été affecté en revanche il y a des
aspects qui sont beaucoup plus
inquiétants c'est à dire qu'il y a des
dégâts matériels à proximité immédiate
de ses réacteurs notamment un bâtiment
de stockage de déchets radioactifs les
systèmes d'arrosage de bassin de
refroidissement et un câble électrique
qui alimente l'un des réacteurs de la
centrale les sites qui fournissent
l'électricité dont l'installation a
forcément besoin évidemment ont été
visés et ceux qui sont derrière ces
bombardements nous diraffel grossit le
patron de la yeah le gendarme du
nucléaire et bien ils savent exactement
où ils ont frappé on voit bien que c'est
extrêmement ciblé donc c'est délibéré ce
qui veut dire aussi que pour cela que ce
soit des Russes ou des Ukrainiens
puisque chacun se rejette la faute
pardonnez-moi une centrale nucléaire est
donc une cible légitime dans ce conflit
ça c'est évidemment inquiétant donc la
ua qui appelle à la mise en place d'une
zone de sûreté autour de cette centrale
je risque la palissade dans centrale
nucléaire il y a le mot nucléaire
Antoine qui avec lui qui avait lui vient
son lot d'inquiétude et ça chaque camp
le sait pertinemment et joue dessus
depuis le début du conflit beaucoup
dessus et évidemment dans une propagande
parce qu'il y a forcément de la
propagande dans une guerre on joue aussi
sur les peurs on tente d'avoir des
soutiens que ce soit de sa population
que ce soit de pays voisins voir plus
lointain et évidemment cette centrale de
zapporage on voit bien qu'elle est au
cœur de la propagande des deux côtés
depuis plusieurs mois c'est la frappe
les frappes les plus violentes depuis
cet été sur zaporigia ce qui fait
craindre d'ailleurs que ça qui est
d'autres fois pardonnez-moi et que cette
fois-ci est bien on n'est pas de chance
pour reprendre les mots de Rafale
grossile le président le patron de la
IEA et qui est à un moment un accident
nucléaire assez là-dessus qu'on joue
parce que évidemment c'est la plus
grande centrale d'Europe qui est un
enjeu stratégique énergétique
extrêmement important et que tout le
monde a en tête ce qui s'est passé à
Tchernobyl en Ukraine en 1986 où il y a
quelques années à Fukushima au Japon et
cela fait peur le nucléaire parce que si
il y a un même missile qui tombe
quelques mètres plus loin et bien c'est
la catastrophe assurée donc évidemment
ça fait peur à tout le monde merci
beaucoup
en tout votre décryp